all right
can you say it yes yes
so hello my name is alberto cenino and
i'm going to give you a very brief
overview of fastpay so this is a five
minute talk so i'm not going to explain
you
how it works i'm just going to say what
it is and
hopefully if you get interested you can
talk to me later so fastpay
is the typical example of research work
we do at novi research
so i hope it gives you a good overview
of the kind of work we do
so first of all this is joint work with
matthew and george
both are researchers and engineers at
facebook movie with me
so what is fastpay sofaspace a
distributed system
a bft system it's a payment
infrastructure
and it is extremely low latency there is
this particular point with respect to
all other payment systems that are
distributed
so fastpay works in the general bft
settings
so it's composed of a set of nodes a set
of authorities
three f plus one authorities of standard
byzantine assumptions
out of which at most f can be malicious
and the goal that we want here the
design of us pay
is to make distributed payment system
practical for retail payments at
physical points of sale
this means that we would like to have
distributed payments uh in such a way
that you can
go to a coffee shop buy coffee pay with
this kind of system and have the
payments
finished and settled straight away and
this of course requires extremely low
latency
arguably much lower latency than what
traditional blockchains
and current state-of-the-art blockchains
give you
so what is the current industry standard
in that respect
so first of all we want low latency we
want
bft resilience of course and we want
fast finality and high capacity
fast finality means that we want to have
a system in such a way that once we make
the payments
it's finalized and settled very quickly
and the payment cannot be reverted
and high capacity means that we want a
lot of users to be able to use the
system
at the same time so the current industry
system does not seem to do a good job at
that at the moment
first of all most of them are extremely
centralized
this means that they often work with
very old master slave implementations
and it incurs enormous
operational costs for instance they need
to make sure that the system is always
up and running what happens when this
master goes down
and we need to switch the slave what
happens um
if the right people should get access to
the system but not the malicious people
and so on and so forth
and secondly they have very slow
formality people may think that
your credit card payments are fast but
actually they're not really payments
they're just promises of payments when
you most of the time when you pay with
your credit card
the provider and the banks will just
emit a promise of payments
and banks will settle the net payment
usually at the end of the day
and this again create huge credit risks
because the merchant's bank needs to
make sure that the money will be there
at the end of the day
so fast pay solve those problems but
fast pay is not blockchain
traditionally blockchain runs a
primitive called byzantine consensus
while fast pay is run on a weaker
primitive which is called byzantine
consistent broadcast this means that
fastpay cannot do all the things that a
blockchain does
but what it do is payments and it can do
them with much lower
latency than what byzantine consensus
can give you
and so that's it if you're interested
come talk to me you have here a link to
the full paper
and that has the full system and how it
works
and a link to the code because we
implemented it tested it extensively
and we show the latency and the
throughput that we get
for a different number of nodes and
different testbeds so i'm happy to take
any questions
if there are any i think i'm exactly one
minute left for that